[Music]
some sad news to report tonight Althea
the Pitbull died this weekend just a few
short weeks after being found on the
street she was severely emaciated but a
local rescue group did everything they
could to give her a second chance at
life Victoria Saha has been following
althea's Journey today she takes a look
at how the pup's Legacy will live on
she's looking better today a
heartbreaking end to a story everyone
desperately hoped would be a miracle she
was a fighter
she had a will in her that
I don't know that I've even experienced
it in a person oh Thea a seven-year-old
Pitbull was found just Skin and Bones
back in November it was clear this pup
was neglected and abused
her condition was so rough chances of
her surviving were slim but Vegas Pet
Rescue project was determined to give
her that chance if we don't
who will we have seen these dogs go
through so we could not in our hearts
and in our soul just say and give up on
it Tina Hayes a volunteer with the
rescue was by althea's side every step
of the way
and since our story first aired about
Althea our Las Vegas viewers were
invested in her journey which meant if
Althea wasn't giving up then neither
were we thankfully to you you are
allowing the community to know what
happened throughout the ever step of the
way and so we're very grateful too
Althea was fighting to live just last
week she was transferred out of
Veterinary emergency and critical care
and able to walk again on her own but
pneumonia hit her full body suddenly and
she was back in the ER ultimately she
fought until she couldn't fight anymore
though while Thea came into the world
not knowing how it felt to be loved and
cuddled she left feeling the warmth of a
gentle touch even if it was for a short
time say bye Victoria Saha 8 News Now
Vegas Pet Rescue project says they will
continue to fight for animals in honor
of Althea over the last few weeks the
reward for any information leading to
her abusers has grown to twenty thousand
dollars